الاتحاد الاوروبي يبحث خطه لتحويل عوائد
الوصول الروسيه المجمده الى اوكرانيا
حاكم فلوريدا
للانتخابات الامريكيه
ومع استمرار ازمه الديون
تصنيف الائتمانيه الامريكي تحت المراقبه
تمهيدا لاحتمال خطه
[موسيقى]
من العربيه افادت صحيفه
البريطانيه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي يبحث
سهوله تحويل مليارات اليوروهات من عوائد
الوصول الروسيه المجمده الى اوكرانيا
وبحسب مصادر الصحيفه فان مسؤولين من الدول
الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي والمفوضيه
الاوروبيه اجتمعوا يوم امس لدراسه
الخيارات لتحويل العوائد التي حققتها منذ
تجميدها من قبل مؤسسه الاوروبيه للخدمات
الماليه وتشير الصحيفه لان هذه الخطوه لا
تعني مصادره الوصول ذاتها لكنها تمثل
تشديدا للضغط المالي على روسيا من قبل
الدول الغربيه ويشار الى ان قيمه الوصول
الروسيه المجمده عند يورو كلير تقدر
بحوالي 200 مليار يورو بما فيها
180 مليارا من اصول البنك المركزي الروسي
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التصدي لهجوم
بحريش النته ثلاثه زوارق اوكرانيه سريعه
مسيره على سفينه ايفانخوس التابعه لاسطول
البحر الاسود في مضيق
وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره انه تم تدمير
جميع القوارب المعاديه في زمن قياسي وان
سفينه الروسيه كانت تقوم بحمايه خطي غاز
ترك ستريم وبلو ستريم في المنطقه
الاقتصاديه التركي
من بيل جورد الى مضيق البوسفور في تركيا
تقول الانباء ان رقعه الصراع بين موسكو
وكيف تتسع صراع انصح ما يقال فانه لم يعد
حبيس الحدود الاوكرانيه والروسيه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت عن تعرض احدى
سفنها لهجوم بزوارق حربيه وفي منطقه خارج
حدودها الاقليميه امر يجعله اول هجوم من
نوعه خلال الحرب الاوكرانيه يقع خارج حدود
الدولتين
الهجوم وقع على بعد 140 كيلومترا شمال
شرقي مضيق البوسفور في المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخالصه التابعه لتركيا واستهدف الهجوم
سفينه ايفانخورس التابعه للبحريه الروسيه
في تمام الساعه الخامسه والنصف فجرا عبر
ثلاثه زوارق هجوميه مسيره عن بعد موسكو
اتهمت كييف بالوقوف وراء الهجوم اتهام لم
تقابله الاخيره برد حتى اللحظه على خلاف
الهجوم الذي استهدف بيلجو الروسيه حيث نفت
اوكرانيا صلتها به
وفقا للدفاع الروسيه فان السفينه
ايفانخورس تقوم بمهام ضمان سلامه عمل خطوط
غاز التيار التركي والتيار الازرق مؤكده
ان الطاقم السفينه تمكن من احباط الهجوم
وتدمير الزوارق المهاجمه
بعد الهجوم الارهابي في السادس والعشرين
من سبتمبر على خط نورس ريم تتخذ القوات
المسلحه الروسيه تدابير لحمايه هذه
المرافق سفينه ايفان خورس التابعه لاسول
البحر الاسود تواصل اداء المهام الموكله
اليها
مؤخرا زادت موسكو من اتهاماتها
لاسيما بعد حصول الاخيره على اسلحه غربيه
نوعيه
اتهامات لا يعرف الى اين ستصل واين ستاخذ
الصراع معها
برد صارم على اي محاولات لتوغل مسلحين
وقراريين للحدود الروسيه مشيرا الى مقتل
70 مسلحا في بيلا جراون ونشرت وسائل
الاعلام الروسيه مقاطع مصوره قالت انها
لمركبات الامريكيه الصلاه استخدمها
المصلحون في الهجوم على منطقه
الحدوديه
وذكرت التقارير الروسيا المواجهات تسببت
في تضرر خمسمائه منزل على الاقل في
المدينه
من جهته اعلن حاكم منطقه بلغراود الروسيه
سلطات المقاطعه شكلت سبع كتائب دفاع تضم
نحو ثلاثه الاف شخص لتامين الحدود مع
اوكرانيا واوضح جالده وفن سلطات تدرس
تسريحه تلك المجموعات مشيرا الى انها
تتدرب منذ نوفمبر الماضي المسؤول الروسي
اكد ان الحاجه لتلك الكتائب ظهرت بعد
الهجوم الاخير
في المقابل قال قائد ما يطلق عليه فيلق
المتطوعين الروس المعارض كابوستين ان
مجموعته ستقوم بعمليات توغل في داخل روسي
قريبا اضاف كابوستينا للمرحله الاولى من
الهجوم عبر استهداف مقاطعه كانت ناجحه وان
العمليه مستمره
خططنا الجديده هي مهاجمه مناطق جديده في
روسيا والتوغل فيها ليس عليكم سوى
الانتظار قليلا لايام عده فقط كي تشاهدون
في الجزء الاخر من الحدود
[موسيقى]
تشير
اطلق الجيش السوداني قضايا من منطقه
المهندسين تجاهها مركز قوات الدعم السريع
هذا وتتواصل الاشتباكات بين طرفي الصراع
وتزيد حدتها في ام درمان وافاده باوند
سودانيه بان قوات الدعم السريع تتاهب لشن
هجوم على مواقع الجيش في محيط منطقه
المهندسين
وفي سياق ذاتها كان مسؤول في البيت الابيض
في تصريحاته العربيه تماسك الهدنه في
السودان لكنه اشار الى انه من المبكر
الحكم عليه الهدف من الهدنه حسب المسؤول
هو السماح للمساعدات الانسانيه بالوصول
للمدنيين كما اضافنا الولايات المتحده
ستنظر في خطوات اخرى في المرحله القادمه
وانها تعمل مع شركائها على اليه لمراقبه
الهدنه في السودان
قال المفوض سامي للامم المتحده لحقوق
الانسان فولكر توك ان اتفاقيات وقف اطلاق
النار لا يتم احترامها كما اشار الى
السودان ما يحدث في السودان لا امر مفجع
على الرغم من اتفاقات وقف اطلاق النار
المتتاليه فاننا نرى انه يتم خرقها في
غضون ساعات نرى كيف يستمر تعرض المدنيين
لخطر الموت والاصابه يعني بين عشيه وضحاها
تلقينا تقارير عن طائرات مقاتله عبر
الخرطوم واشتباكات في بعض مناطق المدينه
وكذلك سماع اطلاق النار في شمال الخرطوم
وفي ام درمان
حاكم فلوريدا الجمهوريه
الانتخابات البيت الابيض من اجل ما وصفه
بقياده العوده الامريكيه العظمى وقال
نيسانتيس في مقطع فيديو نشره على حسابه في
تويتر انا مرشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه من
اجل قياده العوده الامريكيه العظمى
غلبنا الحقيقه على الخوف والتعليم على
التلقين والقانون والنظام على الشغب
والفوضى لقد صمدنا عندما تم تهديد الحريه
اظهرنا اننا نستطيع اعاده احياء امريكا
نحن بحاجه الى الشجاعه للقياده والقوه
للفوز انا روندي سانتوس اعلن ترشح
الانتخابات الرئاسه لقياده العوده
الامريكيه العظمى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مع واحد من اغنى اغنياء العالم ومتابعين
فاقع عددهم المئه واربعين مليونا قرر حاكم
ولايه فلوريدا روند مشاركه منصه تويتر مع
ايلون ماسك لاعلان ترشحه لانتخابات
الرئاسه الامريكيه
قرار راه البعض غير تقليدي ان لم يكن
غريبا ففي العاده الاهتمام الاعلامي
والجماهري يتركز على شخصيه المرشح الذي
يسوق نفسه للناخب وليس على شخصين يتقاسمان
منصه
[تصفيق]
اعتقد ان ديسانتس يشعر ان هذا سيمكنه من
الوصول الى جمهور وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الواسع فهو يريد تجاوز وسائل الاعلام
التقليديه مثل سي ان ان وغيرها من وسائل
الاعلام التي جعلها عدوا
يرى ايلون ماسك شخصيه مؤثره بشكل متزايد
بين المفكرين المحافظين
يطرح نفسه كمرشح الجمهوريين التقليديين
فكحاكم لولايه فلوريدا وقع دي سانتوس على
عدد من القرارات التنفيذيه التي تحرم
الاجهاض بعد سته اسابيع وتعاد المهاجرين
والمثليين والانفاق الحكومي لذا فهو يحاول
استماله مؤيدي الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
كمرشح محافظ دون متاعب ترامب القانونيه
وشخصيته الجدليه المنفره احيانا للناخب
المستقل
سيكون قادرا على التسويق نفسه على انه
دونالد ترامب لكن بدون دراما لكن المشكله
تكمن في انه يريد ان يكون دونالد ترامب
كذلك لكن بدون القدره على تنشيط
المهرجانات الانتخابيه قاعده الحزب
الجمهوري ليست مع ديسانس حتى الان
وبالتالي فان المشكله التي نراها بالنسبه
له هي كيف يمكنه الحصول على الزخم
استطلاعات الراي التضع والترم في المقدمه
بفارقني 30 نقطه عن خصمه لكن هذا قد يتغير
مع بدايه انطلاق الحملات الانتخابيه ودعم
الممولين لذا يخشى ترامب ديسنتس اكثر من
اي مرشح وبدا ينعته
باسمك التقليل من شانه
بعد الاعلان الرسميه سيبدا ديسانتس بعقد
مهرجانات انتخابيه في جميع الولايات خطابه
سيكون يمينيا محافظا لاستماله الاصوات
المتشدده في الحزب الجمهوري قبل ان يتوجه
الى الناخب المستقل في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه امام الرئيس بايدن هذا طبعا اذا
استطاع ان ينتصر على الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب نادي العربيه
في هذه النشره ولكن بعد الفاصل
اسرائيل تشن عمليه تمشيط عسكريه واسعه في
اريحا بحثا عن نشط
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت وكاله للتصنيف
الائتماني انها وضعت تصنيف الائتماني
للولايات المتحده تحت المراقبه تمهيد
الاحتمال خفضه في حال تخلف واشنطن عن سداد
ديونه اذ لم يرتفع او لم يتم سقف الدين
العام الامريكي قالت الوكاله في بيان
الولايات المتحده ما زالت تتمتع حتى الان
بالتصنيف الممتاز لكن قرارها هذا يعكس
التوترات السياسيه المتزايده التي تعيق حل
المشكل عبر رفع سقف الدين العام او تعليق
العمل به في وقت اقترب فيه الموعد النهائي
لبلوغ الدين العام الامريكي السقف المحدد
قانونا
تحولت قضيه رفع سقف الدين العام الامريكي
الى مفاوضات علنيه بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين حول اداره الميزانيه
والاقتصاد الامريكي لا لكنني تحدثت الى
البيت الابيض واخرين وساخبركم بالتطورات
هذا الصباح
يتهم الديمقراطيون الجمهوريين بسوء النيه
في التفاوض والتسبب بعدم رفع سقف الدين
وبازمه اقتصاديه وماليه عالميه بعض الكلام
على منبر مجلس النواب كان قاسيه
نجد انفسنا في هذا الموقع ليس لانه ليس
لدينا المال فنحن اغنى دوله في العالم بل
لان زملائنا الجمهوريين وضعونا في موقع
الرهان
وزير الخزانه جانتيلين تقول ان التمويل
ينفذ بعد ثمانيه ايام ومع ذلك لم يسوت
مجلس الشيوخ الذي يسيطر عليه الديمقراطيون
على اي مشروع قانون لتحاشي المشكله
ومع تقاصر مهله الطرفين في التوصل الى حل
حذرت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جاني من ان
اسواق السندات تتعرض لضغوطات بسبب تاخر
المفاوضات في الوصول الى نتيجه
نرى بعض الضغط في السوق الخزانه واعتقد ان
الامر تذكير بضروره التوصل الى اتفاق في
الوقت المناسب
ولا يبدو ان الطرفين وصل الى اي تفاهمات
فرئيس مجلس النواب كرر في اروقه الكونجرس
كل ما قيل من قبل ولا ما الرئيس بايدن
والديمقراطيين وطالب بخفض المصروفات ووقف
الاستدامه سارسل المفاوضين الى البيت
الابيض في محاوله للتوصل الى اتفاق فنحن
لا زلنا على خلاف عميق في عدد من القضايا
يتصرف الجمهوريون والديمقراطيون وكان
لديهم الوقت الكافي للتوصل الى اتفاق قبل
ان تضطر وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه الى وقف
بعض المدفوعات
في الغنمه العربيه من امام وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه
تتواصل العمليه العسكريه التي بدات القوات
الاسرائيليه في مدينه اريحا ومخيم عقبه
جبر مصادر اسرائيليه قالت لنا العمليه
تستهدف القضاء على خليه من المسلحين نشطه
مؤخرا في المنطقه قد شوهدت عشرات المركبات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه المعززه بجرافات
تقتحم المدينه وتقوم باغلاق طرق جانبيه
قبل ان تتوغل في المخيم وتقتحم منازل
الفلسطينيين وتعتقل عددا من الشبان وسط
مواجهات واشتباكات متفرقه
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه سياره تابعه لقواته
استهدفت من الاراضي السوريه وردا على ذلك
اطلق الجيش الاسرائيلي النار نحو مصدر
الهجوم قال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
وفخاري ادرعي ان المسيره كانت تقوم بمهمه
الروتينيه في المنطقه مشيرا الى ان
المسيره انجزت مهامها ولم تسجل اي اضرار
منع القضاء اللبناني حاكما المصرف المركزي
رياض سلامه من السفر بعد استجوابه سلامه
كان مثل امس امام المحامي العامه تمييزي
في بيروت واستمرت الجلسه ساعه وعشرين
دقيقه
حجز بنتيجه الحجز بنتيجتها المحامي العام
جوازي سفر حاكم مصرف لبنان الفرنسي
واللبناني وتركه بعد التحقيق
قال نائب رئيس المجلس الرئاسي الليبي عبد
الله اللافي ان اعضاء لجنه 6 + 6 المجتمعه
في المغرب
سيتوافقون خلال اليومين المقبلين على
قوانين وتشريعات تلبي تطلعات وامال
الليبيين خلال المرحله الحاليه للوصول
للانتخابات
اللجنه سته زائد سته المنعقده الان في
المغرب
نتمنى لهذه اللجنه التوفيق الشعب الليبي
ينتظر من هذه اللجنه التوافق حول اصدار
القوانين والتشريعات اللازمه لانجاز مشروع
الانتخابات الذي ينتظره الليبيون
نتمنى ان يتم هنا يكون هناك توافق بين
اللجنتين من مجلس النواب مجلس الدوله
الشعب الليبي ينتظرهم اكيد في خلال يومين
القادمين سنسمع ان شاء الله اخبار حول
توافق من خلال انجاز قوانين وتشريعات تلبي
المرحله وتصلنا الى الانتخابات ان شاء
الله
وكذا الاتحاد العامه للشغل الانتهاء من
الصيغه النهائيه لمبادره الحوار الوطني
التي تهدف لانقاذ البلاد على حد وصف
الاتحاد اتحاد الشغل اوضح انه سيتم عرض
المبادره على الحكومه والاحزاب السياسيه
ومكونات المجتمع المدني خلال الفتره
المقبله
توفي سته اشخاص واصيب ثمانيه عشر اخرون
جراء الحرائق التي اشتعلت في مخيمات
النازحين بمحافظه مارب خلال النصف الاول
من العام الجاري وبحسب تقرير اصدرت الوحده
التنفيذيه لاداره مخيمات النازحين بالمغرب
فقد بلغ عدد الحرائق في مخيمات النازحين
بالمحافظه واحد وسبعين حريقا موزعا على
عدد من المخيمات في مديريتي المدينه
هكذا يصبح النازحون مشردين مجردين من كل
شيء في صراع العيش بين الكوارث المتعاقبه
سميره التي نجت واسرتها من كارثه حريق هي
الخامسه في هذا المخيم كان مصيرها احسن
حال من جيرانها الذين فقدوا ابنتهم بين
النيران وسط مدينه مارب
مش ولا حاجه لا خيام لاما ولا شيء لما
حرقه اخر مره اصبحنا مشردين بكل الشوارع
المره الاولى محرقنا لنا شهر ونصف مندوب
ولا شيء
والله ما داري بحالتنا احنا الا غير الله
في لحظه توثيقي ماساه النازحين المنشغلين
بتجميع حطام مساكنهم المحترقه
وجدناهم في العرائم انهكون بعد مقاومه
الرياح والامطار طالبنا اكثر من مره
ينقلنا من هذه البقعه لانه كل مره نفس
الترابيل نفس الخيام نفس الموضوع تكرر كل
مره وبالتالي تتكرر الحرائق والماسي
الوحده التنفيذيه للنازحين رصدت ما يزيد
عن سبعين حادثه للحرائق في المخيمات راح
ضحيتها سته من النساء والاطفال خلال النصف
الاول من العام الجري ارقام تتضاعف
للضحايا وحلول انقاذ النازحين من المؤقت
سريع الاشتعال لم تنفذ
هناك استجابه ضعيفه من بعض الشركاء مثل
هذا النموذج الذي اقيمها عباره عن كنتيره
خفت او حدت من الحرائق داخل المحافظه لمن
امتلكه
هذه طبعا لازال هناك بعض الاسر تعيش في
الماء والمؤقت وهي القيم والترابيل وهذه
اكثرهم عرضه لمثل هذه الحرائق بين ليله
وضحاها يتعرض النازحون في مارب لماسم
متعدده نتائجها تكرار مراره التشرد
وفقدان الماوى وادواته
من كوارث الامطار والس
يول ازدادوا
معانانا في محافظه مارب في ظل غياب
التدخلات الانسانيه محمود الحميدي العربيه
مارب
بعد نجاحه صوره انفجار مقر وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ونفاها
البنتاجون تراجعت البورصه لفتره قصيره
لكنها كانت كفيله بجعل المستخدمين لا
يثقون باخبار تويتر ويوجهون اتهامات
للملياردير الامريكي الى الماسك بجعل
المنصه ارضا خصبه للاخبار الزائفه
انفجار في البنتاجون
لحظه انها صوره مزيفه فبركها الذكاء
الاصطناعي لكنها تظهر مفارقه تكنولوجيه في
عالم تويتر لاننا شرها يمتلك اشاره زرقاء
ما يعني حسابا موثقا علق حساب بلومبرج لكن
المستخدمين تداولوها قبل الحذف خاصه وانهم
صدقوها ولو لوهله حتى البورصه الامريكيه
هوت لوقت وجيز ثم انهالوا على ملك تويتر
كيف جعل العلامه الزرقاء ذات ثمانيه
دولارات لمن يدفعها لا لمن يستحق التوثيق
اي انه جعل تويتر ارضا خصبه لاخبار كاذبه
تؤدي الى فوضى عارمه خبراء التقنيه قالوا
انهم حتى لو علموا بان علامه التوثيق
الزرقاء لم تعد تشير الى الشرعيه فمن
الصعب كسر عاده بصريه اكتسبها المغردون
على مدار 15 عاما
دمار نفته الدفاع الامريكيه لكن رماده
وبحسب الخبراء جعل من تويتر منصه لم تعد
قابله للتصديق
في الختام تذكير بالعناو
الاتحاد الاوروبي يبحث خطه لتحويل عوائد
الاصول الروسيه المجمده الى اوكرانيا
حاكم فلوريدا يعلن ترشحه للانتخابات
الامريكيه
ومع استمرار ازمه الديون
تحت المراقبه تمهيدا لاحتمال خطه
نهايتها بالنشره المزيد على العربيه بعد
قليل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات